le président des états unis ça a bardé
d'état bléneau et et hier une conférence
de presse à la maison blanche c'est une
maison en fait comme dans le jeu oui
tout est blanc ciel qu'à l'époque de
c'est du propre qui sont ses vrais la
maison blanche est toute blanche dedans
xi mais
les boiseries d'objets maison blanche on
écoute tu vas fermer ta gueule
mais là une cabane de plage
alors il ya une conférence de presse à
la maison blanche et ça clairement
déraper jusqu'à insulter un journaliste
en passant avoir le micro coupé joe
biden je l'aimé pas je l'aimé pas mais
j'aime bien et on dit ça on aime bien il
est mais j'étais pas comment parce qu'il
fait pas beaucoup parler lui non mais là
non plus à
le voter pour lui en
france
savait pas où je découvre je
regarde
[Musique]
il n'y a pas l'air en forme de ouf
c'est pas là
mais alors moi je kiffe dubaï moi je
manque sans musique aux états unis oui
parce que il est arrivé justement en
disant qu'il allait être le présente
deux de large ouverture et de la
réconciliation des américains et la
voilà donc il est dans une sorte de
continuité de ce qu'il avait dit qu'il
ne ferait plus mûr et après autrement
énorme polémique aux états unis mais il
a bien joué parce qu'une heure après il
a appelé le journaliste qui l'avait
insulté et il lui a dit un jour à mes de
fox news qui sont hostiles il lui a dit
rien de personnel l'ami et le
journaliste et le journaliste a dit
c'est bien il a autre chose à faire il a
pris le temps de s'excuser et c'est donc
du coup ça se retourne ccsa devient
finalement comme trou dans la politique
c'est pas du tout ce qui s'est passé ça
alors
m
oui oui c'est l'ennui au rayon en rayon
oui au rayon masque de nuit d'accord
yves rocher d'entreprise
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]